I'm using the right for pancreatic cancer, but my doctor is saying they aren't even sure it's coming from the pancreas as where RGCC tests came back unsure.
But I would trust the RGCC test for where my cancer is.
So it gets back to the biopsy.
And I can't remember your case, whether you're at a biopsy or not.
And if you had a biopsy, sure pancreatic cancer, then I'd go off of that.
Although I do have a system at pancreas, does this mean my right program might not be doing anything if it's not pancreatic cancer?
If you could kind of mean that, you don't have just pancreatic cancer programated there, but you know, yeah, I mean, you want to be as specific as possible.
So let's say, let's say you have, I mean, there's really any other cancer that's going to test the size of the pancreas.
So you could have a cyst that is a demon cancerous, assist on your pancreas.
And it's not pancreatic cancer, whether you're actually running the right preventative, the pancreatic cancer.
They're saying it's definitely coming from somewhere dealing with a digestive system.
My doctor is almost sure it's pancreas, but not 100%.
If you want, said it at Jigsaw, but I can give you a secondary program for annual carcinoma, which is 95% of the cancers that are other digestive in nature.
If you want to do that, I can do that.
So for sure, then you could run like every other night or something.
I would like to try if that man is off as well, would love your thoughts on how much you take.
I would, if you're going to try, then that is all I was going to try, then that is all that's best way to put it.
I would do one pack a day, four days a week.
So one pack a day comes in individual packs.
We can't sell it on our store. Sorry, we can sell it, but we can't have it up on our store.
There's the beta that the FDA came after us because of what we had on the listing.
We could probably put it back on the store as long as we don't say anything about cancer because other places have it.
So I think we could actually put it back on our store if we just took off anything about using the cancer or how we would use it.
Just do one pack a day, you could mix it in your smoothie.
That's the best way to do it.
The first and do it only four days a week.